in a real smell out on the log reading
the piece how you guys doing
we're with two special guests professor
Deborah Majeed she may find herself with
only two choices one to remain single
and two to take a husband who at some
time in their marriage may take another
woman as his wife
the reel-to-reel that we keep it down in
d-10 Daily Show we encourage people to
come to us and ask an imam moussa and
we're going to be talking about be for
the stars of the reality TV show Sister
Wives a federal appeals court reverses a
landmark decision that decriminalized
Polly of polygamy in Utah the family
sued over Utah's ban on plural marriages
at the local prosecutors announced they
may charge Koli Brown part of that show
and his wives the ruling says the family
can't sue because charges were never
filed and authorities have not said they
won't prosecute consenting adult
polygamists and lady me polygyny now
it's very very some people find it very
strange because usually men will talk
about it but now to meet a professor who
actually wrote a thesis on it and fill
us in what else are you doing on this
we all cook for one I want to help our
society bit and listen to better
understand what pure marriage is about
and what Islam personalized this idea of
polygamy when a husband here is marshal
wife has completed so we're trying to
correct the misconception that polygamy
is either mandated by law or dictated by
Islam as much as provisioning was
regulated by the Prophet Muhammad and
that those who taxes the different years
and the United States have great
responsibilities and so mask is across
the country and across the world in my
view much more intent on supporting
healthy marriage with Everly one imam
moussa tell us is this something that in
your in your community or a lot of not
yet muslims they bring this up and what
do you usually say when this is brought
up in the issue it really a very tough
topic to talk about
until recently especially in India and
from India when the government tried to
interfere with the mission of the law
particularly talking about the divorce
many of the sisters to discrete
practicing educated well qualified
professional sisters who has defended
the right the clergyman and said that if
we find peace and security
what do you why do you think this has
been so demonized when this is something
throughout history it was something that
was common yeah but because in the
United States we have living is this a
law a civil law requires us to have
remanded taken once real life and so we
have unfortunately have too many
experiences of the factions of
caliginous that has been done in
contrast to what not only islam teaches
what the Quran said so we have too many
bad experience many people who are
victims of abuse there's the whole
spiritual emotional and otherwise so
it's only natural for people to look at
the number of victims and think that
these practices that say what do you
think it is so indeed only the bad
things get the news and bad news becomes
the news there are a lot of numerous
examples where people are enjoying the
life and family as together they really
enjoy the fruits of the polygamy if it
can be practiced in accordance with the
business of God Muhammad gave your
opinion and instruction given by Allah
Allah Allah
he can be blessed we see that this is
something that is you know all the
messengers of God you know they
practices it's it's clearly outlined in
the Bible we see that throughout history
it was something that was that was that
was common we see that today that when a
man has multiple mistresses when he's
fooling around like many of these
politicians not caring or loving for
these women just using and abusing you
know this seems you know to be normal
it's not something looked down upon but
when someone wants to go ahead and care
for these women and many you know a lot
of times what's the solution there
there's so many more women than men out
there and many you know who can't get
married or you know many have either
lost their husbands or whatnot what's
the solution you know what do you do so
first of all we need
education both among Muslims and Muslims
in their context with nothing
polygamy is only one form of marriage
and the collide as we can clearly
understand is positioning us for
monogamy we ask religion is practiced
and it's practice according to the
decisions that are outlined and
described we see blessings in those
relationships we see blessings we see
live live receive children
living vibrant and in vibrant loving
household the problem is that even
though some people talk about trying to
assist those who would not have mirrors
available to them any other way too
often they are using and abusing it's
very important in our society in across
the milk in the world that the forms of
marriage that take place are ones which
women have agencies women are making a
choice that they are freely entering the
types of unions that they are that the
Masjid that perform ceremonies where the
monogamous or polygamous provides a
resources the emotional and
psychological care to strengthen
marriages whatever the form in the
United States we know that marriage is
into the voice of 50 percent of the time
right
so in Islamic community like other
communities
need to have some strong education and
guidance we need to help guide
individuals into is happy and healthy
home and not just had marriage because
they have their the opportunity so I'm
saying that in the fourth collision II
what it means when african-american
Muslim women share their husband is
advocating the decriminalization of
provisioning and encouraging Masjid to
spend more time more resources more care
on fostering an environment while
healthy marriages disease
shake what have you noticed we when we
talk to some of the moms they're saying
a lot of women are upset you know the
women are coming forward and saying why
aren't you advocating on our behalf and
you can't get married and you know
they've closed this door what have you
have you seen some of this happening I
have seen a couple of Koreans were
convicted odd however they have found
that the resistance come forward with
this kind of message not only the
husband have encouraged but also among
they should also because this is Imams
and amount will be open to this
suggesting to determine all in their own
populace it needs to be a discussion
among the youth as well I have seen that
mod of youth have this question and if
this is answer we can easily introduce
the existence of the Britany in the
little environment where many things can
be avoided by having practice mistake
Roberts on determine that is need to be
talked about like system is given I
would like to see more and more success
come forward and talk about it the
benefit of the others to see the good
method and we'll conclude with one more
question
sister professor what do you usually say
when you I'm sure you deal with a lot of
emotion emotional people who when you
bring this up you know you get a lot of
backlash you get a lot of women that
will come at you emotionally and how do
you tackle give us a true life story and
you know how do you deal with this
bottom line the emotionality comes out
of hurt and pain and fear and what we
noticed in polygamous marriages the
challenges religious carriages are also
evident in the challenges of monogamous
marriages right so that's why I'm
advocating for stronger resources which
it wouldn't need to be married but many
of us don't nobody needs to live
unhealthy allow single minors and
preparing ourself for me and those
individuals who are acting as our
Guardians as is our while leaves so to
speak they need to be educated too they
need to know what it means to look out
for the best interest of the women
involved and then the women have
depreciated about the kind of a table
with this north and that we don't have
to settle and we don't have to take for
left just the interim to the status
community what's your book called and
where can people figure out its validity
what it means when african-american
Muslim women when African American
Muslim women share their husband it is
published by University Press of Florida
is on Amazon and right now is in
paperback for $15 or less last one last
one
have you heard another sensible sensible
solution to the growing crisis that has
anyone presented you with something to
solve the prong cause there are
obviously more have workers a solution
we decide this one where community and
clear communities are able to bring men
and
together and give them healthy options
of living a male life regardless of
their status we see more healthy males
thank you thank you so much professor
closing comments and I would like to see
that what you're doing is one of the
best thing that we can do in this is
that college and luckily the harshest
issue for all this time and the reason
we people have got a clear health and
north
I would like body to be distant and talk
about more openly and the more we talk
about it more examples come into this
life people would be able to handle this
in more appropriate last but not the
least the more we talk about this among
of ourselves I would like the sisters to
take lead and when anybody is desiring
to enter into this relationship they
need to be open nothing of these things
to be done in secrecy the minute you do
in secrecy that you yourself is not
confident that will make you unfit to
enter in this contract to begin with and
when people exercise these things in
secrecy it can literally open the door
for some abuse and negligence towards
the right that Islam demands from the
husband and wife towards each other so
it must be discussed openly is what
we've done in community and community
should come to know of this so they can
seize an item is a very healthy approach
to caliginous analogy
thank you guys very much Thank You
professor imam moussa so we're going to
close it up also you have your wife is
here and you like to add to this yes
alhamdulillah I'm really blessed in this
regard that a lot of tunnels that I had
breakfasted understanding whether I ever
practiced it or not the fact that she
understand the right of allah subhanaw
taala and her right and she supports and
strongly stand by it is the fact that we
understand that we many Muslims need to
understand what were the limitations are
I see my wife game design her own
limitations she understand the right of
Allah has enjoin upon the husband and
she stands with it and she said there
were a lot of made it permissible for
you for my discontent and she feels that
in two ways one if you find a system if
you get divorces and relate and work
together to advance the cause of this
being she said it's a excess of what I
will have and plus having the progeny
through this also increases the almost
even or so remote a lot of them she
seems to be very passionate when it come
to that
she said that even when you have more
kids I would be able to help them and
support them in sama-sama girls and
accuse fall and ascension we've talked
about this even my daughter takes part
and she said that I would suddenly be
enjoying as an extra burden systems and
extra remember in the family as well is
there what advice do you give for people
wanting to extend their family make a
bigger family and many of the sisters
who are having a very hard time
accepting this
[Music]
it is like anything him before Ana de
Calma Calma Calma make it hannah for any
man why we have to make it difficult for
him the first we have to access a new
performance in Hana Hana to guide Batman
particularly in Sharma and the balance
between both of them I mean for me I
feel another one coming with some for
the unfortunate loss panatela and commit
more Oh Muhammad Ahmad's and guru and
guru for both eventually
thank you so much